all right we turn now to another blatant
double standard on the left and that is
the mob the media
their treatment of donald trump versus
the treatment of joe biden
we'll call this a special hannity
investigation because without a doubt
joe biden's first couple of months
they've been an unmitigated disaster
he's not even getting his radical new
green deal socialist
agenda through as evidenced by tonight
but
if you're dumb enough to rely on oh the
new york times
as your sole only source for news
i doubt you'd have any idea that
president sippy cup
that guy is struggling and
failing on every front the headlines
from the times
it read likes it reads like a beautiful
love story praising biden
for his vaccine push the vaccine donald
trump gave him
touting biden's constructive meeting
with vladimir putin
he gave putin a waiver on a pipeline to
build
while canceling the keystone xl pipeline
and firing 11 000 americans
and then of course they like to at the
new york times cherry pick polls
that always show biden in a favorable
light but even more telling
are the stories that the times will
ignore we call this
bias by omission for example the new
york times like the rest of the media
they say almost nothing about joe
biden's
cognitive issues or massive inflation
or the unemployment rate or the numerous
scandals surrounding
hunter biden many of which now implicate
directly his father
who was caught two and a half weeks ago
in a lie saying he's never talked to
hunter about his foreign
business dealings but yet we have
pictures of joe biden
with hunter's farm business partners
we'll have more on that in a moment
but needless to say we have an
information crisis in the country
the times the rest of the media mob
they're bending over backwards every
second minute hour of every day to
protect joe biden
and it wasn't remains a very different
story
with president trump because from the
moment donald trump
and melania trump came down that
escalator at trump tower
in 2015 continuing to this day
the so-called newspaper of record they
have been
stalking never-ending stalking of donald
trump
the same with the three broadcast
networks and two fake news cable
channels
now literally they spent five long years
spewing lies
a conspiracy theory one after another
and a huge hoax on the american people
they smeared members of the president's
family they
pushed the phony russian disinformation
dossier that hillary clinton paid for
they used that to attack donald trump in
2018 it was ben
smith my buddy himself he published the
new york times op-ed detailing
how proud he was of himself for
publishing hillary clinton's
bought and paid for dirty russian
disinformation dossier
a year later he stated quote the broad
outline
of what christopher steele was writing
is unquestionably true
no ben it was unquestionably false
it was full of russian misinformation
and russian lies
and you are willing dupe in all of this
and the new york times and their
deceptive coverage
didn't stop there here are a few more
examples take a look
first of all i think we need to start
asking ourselves and i think in
particular republican leaders in
congress
need to start asking themselves at what
point do we stop giving the benefit of
the doubt here
um we just the evidence here of these
close
ties with russia continue to mount with
each and every day
but i think this is the more significant
quote i
faced great pressure because of russia
that's taken off
it sure seems to fit one of the elements
that there was obstruction of justice
no robert s mueller iii has been
examining
two chief questions ties between donald
trump's campaign
and russia and whether trump as
president
has tried to obstruct that investigation
i don't know if i can explain it as well
as i did before
if they get a report from the justice
department
they will likely certainly take
impeachment seriously
if not begin an impeachment process
against the president
they reported lie after lie after lie
they spewed conspiracy theory after
conspiracy theory and as we speak
the new york times their washington
correspondent maggie haberman
covers donald trump nearly get this nine
times more than the current president
joe biden
when are they going to stop giving joe
and hunter the benefit of the doubt to
quote them
it's completely insane they stalk donald
trump they still stalk donald trump
and they kiss the ass of and they
protect joe biden
and his corrupt crack addict son hunter
joe biden is in the oval office maggie
ben
joe is in the oval office maybe it's
time to start doing your job
the new york times the rest of the media
mob they're nothing more than green new
deals socialist
and propagandists they lie they push
their agenda
they push propaganda misinformation and
they pretend to be something that
they're not journalists
they are in fact nothing but modern-day
version of pravda
this newspaper is not only biased it is
corrupt and it is dishonest in fact
right now the new york times is facing
multiple major defamation lawsuits
and a pretty amazing decision the new
york supreme court
not an easy place to win a case they
refused to dismiss
a lawsuit from project veritas and they
have now granted project veritas and
james o'keefe
discovery sarah palin's defamation sued
against the new york times that is still
ongoing and that appears headed for
trial
in july i can't wait and the times is
also facing
a suit from covington high school
student nicholas sandman
i'm predicting they'll probably pay him
tens and tens of millions of dollars
because they defamed his character told
lies about him
as many other media outlets will likely
likely be paying
mr sandman a fortune the new york times
the rest of the media mob
they're not interested in truth they're
interested in destroying their political
enemies that's far more important to
them
and with all the venom all the hate all
the ink
all the vitriol they're all clearly
addicted to all things donald trump
and the reality is psychologically for
them
they cannot quit their psychotic
addiction to donald trump
they miss him more than anybody my
message to the
times my message to the rest of the
media mob is simple
it's time for you to tell the truth it's
time for you to
own your own truth you are radical
leftist
new green deal trump hating trump
obsessed
uh new green deal socialist that's who
you are
you're kind of like a talk show host you
claim to be journalists and you're not
you're partisan propagandist and it's
very easy to
expose all of your lying and your agenda
the diff the difference for example
between me and you
it's simple but yet it's kind of
profound i'm honest about who i am
i am a member of the press i'm a talk
show host
we do and i could produce thousands of
hours of straight news
thousands of hours of investigative
reporting that you're too lazy to do
i give my opinion i'm upfront about my
conservative political
beliefs i do sports we do culture i'm
like the entire newspaper
you say you're a journalist you're not
journalist and tonight by the way
we'll start with the new york times
because i'm calling on ben smith
maggie hag haberman and other so-called
journalists at the times
just start being honest about who you
are and what you believe
and that you have an agenda and maybe
you can start answering the questions
that i posed today in an op-ed on
foxnews.com
which brings us to another big
difference between me and them
and we tell the truth they spread lies
and conspiracy theories about
trump and russia and collusion things
that never happen
we expose deep state abuse of power and
corruption
and even they now cling to lies that are
been proven false over and over again
does the new york times
now acknowledge that christopher
steele's dossier bought and paid for by
hillary clinton and the dnc
was filled with russian disinformation
will you admit the truth finally
do you still believe did you ever really
believe in the
trump russia collusion hoax or were you
just advancing a political agenda from
day one
will you ever investigate the millions
of dollars
that joe biden's son zero experience
hunter
made by selling access to daddy
how would you cover it if it was donald
trump's sons will the times or the rest
of the media ever cover
biden his family with the same tenacity
that they covered the trump
family or the feelings of their far left
readers are more important
well maggie haberman will ben smith will
their colleagues acknowledge
that their deceptive coverage of trump
and russia and phony collusion for three
years
that makes them unworthy of the pulitzer
prizes they got
do they plan on returning it did they
not understand
they didn't deserve it the reporters at
the times got the biggest story in their
lifetime
wrong dead wrong this show got it right
there was no trump russia collusion the
dirty dossier
that they say was truthful was russian
disinformation all along
they did the very thing that they were
complaining trump did
but didn't and not only did they get it
wrong they got fake pulitzer prizes
for the efforts so maggie haberman if
you have any integrity
the new york times if you have any
integrity give them back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else